a great man is hard on himself
a small man is hard on others Confucius
a man with good character
will look at himself honestly
and take responsibility for his own
actions changing himself to improve
himself by the weaker man
will never look at himself he will
always blame others for his own faults
and in so doing he will never improve
himself
What a Sad life that must be
success is no accident it is hard work
perseverance learning
studying
sacrifice
and most of all love of what you are
doing or learning to do Pele you know
being lazy will bring you absolutely
nothing in life
well actually it will bring you two
things only two things
one poverty
two a life without purpose
you need to work hard for your goals
without giving up and even if you do
fail at times consistency will bring you
success
integrity means doing the right thing
even when no one is watching C.S Lewis
do you have integrity do you do the
right thing even when no one is watching
because those men who have integrity
they do the right thing all the time
just because it is right not because
someone else is watching and they fear
what they might think
I would absolutely recommend against
excessive positivity and optimism any
positive emotion that you're infusing
into a workplace needs to be grounded in
reality if it's not realistic sincere
meaningful and individualized it won't
do much good some Wrath
being positive is nice but
it will be worthless if it's not
Anchored In Truth and in reality
think about this for a moment being
positive won't change reality you can be
positive that the sky is pink but it's
not going to happen it is blue here's
the key expecting and being ready for
any possible outcome will make you
positive
think about that for a moment
the key to having a fulfilled life is
not to just focus on the outcome of
everything you do but on controlling
your mind to take all your thoughts
captive to have control over your life
meaning you do the best in everything
that you do irrespective of the outcome
it doesn't matter
what will happen whatever happens
happens if it's good great if it's not
great what is important is if you did
your best then you can be happy with
yourself
reaching the mountain your goals the
vision that you have reaching it is not
just all about that it's about the whole
journey towards the summit
don't be like those kind of guys who are
like oh I hope this is going to work oh
I just have to be positive this is going
to work this is going to work and then
it doesn't work and then you get just
down in the dumps and you're depressed
no you just brush it off you learn from
that failure and you move forward
a fool thinks himself to be wise but a
wise man knows himself to be a fool
William Shakespeare
the more you grow in wisdom the more you
start to realize that we as humans know
actually nothing and that you personally
know nothing because there's so much
more to still learn
that is why fools Only Fools always
think that they are always right in all
situations only the wise know that
there's always more than one way of
looking at something
that's why Proverbs 12 15 says the way
of a fool is right in his own eyes but a
wise man listens to advice
we all want progress but if you're on
the wrong road progress means doing an
about turn and walking back to the right
Road in that case the man who turns back
the soonest is the most Progressive C.S
Lewis
what road are you on right now and where
is it leading you towards
progress and success will mean
absolutely nothing to you if it's gained
in a wrong way
in fact it might actually haunt you for
the rest of your life
you need to live life in such a way that
you can sleep at night with a clear
conscience
a successful man will profit from his
mistakes and try again in a different
way Dale Carnegie if you never try then
you will never know
thousands of unsuccessful men never try
because they fear failure
successful men are successful because
they don't fear failure
they actually go full speed into it and
use it to achieve success
try not to become a man of success but
rather try to become a man of value
Albert Einstein now this puts a lot of
things into perspective doesn't it
but I would say that those who become
men of value
are also men who have become successful
well done is better than well said
Benjamin Franklin
every man can talk but can you walk your
talk are you a man that keeps his
promises do you do what you promised
that you would do
or are you just one of those guys who
always just talk
you know these days so many guys have
opinions but opinions doesn't make the
world better it doesn't change anything
actions do
it is not what he has or even what he
does which expresses the worth of a man
but what he is
Henry Frederick Emil a man sees as he is
think about that for a moment
what it means let it sink in
your character influences everything in
your life how you think how you speak
and how you act everything
and you know people can take many things
from you in this short temporary world
but they can never take your integrity
unless you let them
you need to always remember that no
amount of money can buy a man of good
character
we are what we repeatedly do Excellence
is not an act but a habit Aristotle
no man can improve himself if he doesn't
change his habits it is silly and it's
just dumb to think that you can change
yourself if you keep on doing the same
things over and over and over
if you really want to change yourself
it starts by changing your habits and it
can be done
old habits can be changed into new ones
in a period of two to three weeks maybe
sometimes four depending on the person
you are and what habits you have but it
is worth it in the end start to change
your daily routine if you truly want to
improve yourself as a man this is where
you need to start
for a man to conquer himself is the
first and noblest of all victories Plato
you know in this new generation that we
live people always say if you feel like
it just do it let your emotions lead you
but if you do that if you are controlled
by your own emotions being a slave to it
you are no different than an animal
no man can truly achieve his goals if he
does not have discipline and
self-control because to reach those High
Peaks your goals you need to work at it
every day even when you don't feel like
it
the only thing necessary for the Triumph
of evil is for good men to do nothing
Edmund Burke
evil has been gaining huge ground in the
last few years all because the devil is
convincing good men to stay silent to do
absolutely nothing not to go against the
current
because of fear
we need real men to rise up again to get
a backbone
to overcome evil with good
because God has not given us a spirit of
fear but of power of love and
self-control
a fool gives full vent to his anger but
a wise man keeps himself under control
King Solomon
you know it takes a lot to build a good
character little by little over time to
build your reputation to build honor
but it also takes just one word careless
words spoken in Anger by you to break it
all down
to change people's perception of you
be careful of what you say have some
self-control and think before you speak
God has given us a spirit of
self-control it is dumb it's a fool that
just lives on this way of saying I can't
control myself
it's a dangerous life
because when you do things when you say
things you can never take it back
and when you look back on your life if
that's the way you've been living you've
probably caused a lot of Destruction
God can forgive you can take it all away
but you need to start here change
yourself
and then move forward
learn to live through the spirit
self-control power love
do to others whatever you would like
them to do to you Jesus Christ
you know this is one of my favorites
it's called the golden rule for a reason
you know if everybody did this then we
would almost have a perfect life here on
Earth
but many people who wrongly understand
the Bible negatively say it's just full
of rules and laws and I don't care about
it that's how they feel emotionally
right and then they try to rationalize
it with eyes it's the book I don't want
to follow it I want to do what I want to
do
that's actually just an excuse for
saying you want to live in sin
so let me stop you just here to think
about what you're actually saying here
let me ask you this question why would
you view rules against theft
murder
rape
pedophilia
against all evil as negative
this means that you think of all these
things are okay if people do it to live
in this sick world full of sin
if that's what you're actually thinking
then there's nothing wrong with the
Bible but there's a lot wrong with you
and all these laws can actually just be
summed up in one thing
love your neighbor as yourself love
other people as you love yourself
that is what this quote is about Jesus
himself said in Matthew 7 verse 12 so
whatever you wish
that others would do to you do also to
them for this is the law and the
prophets now for those of you who are
not Christian who do not understand this
when it says the law and the prophets
the law and the prophets is just
basically the Bible especially also the
Old Testament it all comes down to only
one thing
love other people as you love yourself
due to them what you want them to do to
you
now as a man focus on the things that
actually matter
be a man of integrity be a man of good
character improve yourself
be the man that you can be that God
created you to be he's got a purpose for
you there's a reason why you are here so
in everything that you do find your
identity in him and bring him on her
before you go always remember that life
is short so don't waste yours cheers
guys